A big part of language learning is
starting to notice the patterns of the
language. Every time you pay a little
attention to a word or a phrase that you
have saved, a LingQ, let's say, that you
move the status up from two to three,
which you can do manually. Let's say that
you create a tag ,let's say that you
review your LingQs of the day, which are
sent to you according to a a spaced
repetition system, in other words
designed to help you remember them
before you completely forget them. All of
these things help you notice, and you
should pay attention when you see
certain phrases, maybe phrases that you
have saved and tagged if you hear them
again, try to pay a little attention to
it. The more you deliberately try to
notice things, whether it be
pronunciation, structure, relationship
between words that might have similar
meanings, all of this effort to notice is
gonna help your brain eventually keep
these things in your long-term memory. So
make an effort to notice.